[Music]
[Applause]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to my show
today is going to be
really interesting we're talking
bitfinex we're talking tether and i have
a really exciting guest but as always
this is powered by icon plus i'm going
to give you a really quick news
announcement so
this one's really interesting pay coin
is the very first company
to commercialize bitcoin payments in
south korea and will also actually
integrate ics
and ethe into its global payment app so
that's really interesting
this is sponsored by blockbuy um you can
actually earn up to 8.6 percent interest
on your uscc
so i will leave a link for you somewhere
and you can get 250
when you sign up and it is powered and
sponsored by coinflip as well so quick
shout out to them
so before i bring on my guest and before
we jump into this um if you are watching
on youtube then please
don't forget to hit the like button
please don't forget to subscribe so you
never miss
one of these fantastic guests joining me
today
we have haley lennon partner at anderson
kill law and contributor for
forbes crypto haley great to have you
how are you doing hi great thanks for
having me
it's very exciting to come on it's good
to have you i feel like we've been
chatting for ages and we've been trying
to schedule something in but it's just
been
it's been madness how are you over in
california
good i am yeah it's been i thought
things might calm down with covid and
it's been quite the opposite
um i just re i was based in san
francisco the last four years and just
relocated
outside of san francisco so that's been
a nice sort of change of pace
and like you said i joined anderson kill
it's been about four months those four
months have flown by
and i'm really enjoying it i'm helping
to grow out
the regulatory practice um there we
we have four or five partners including
uh
preston byrne and stephen palley which
are both also active on twitter
um as other partners at the firm and so
we're just growing out our practice
there for crypto and fintech companies
it's
it's been really fun yeah and i think i
think people like yourself who are
in the regulatory side of things i think
are so interesting and brilliant to chat
to because
on twitter it's kind of just like this
hub where we're all sort of just
crowding and shouting things and ideas
but realistically you know
we need to know how this is all going to
play out in the grand scheme of things
you know
what's mass adoption going to look like
so i'm excited to jump in
but before we do how did you get into
cryptics i don't know
a lot about you personally so tell me
your journey
yeah it's been interesting so i
graduated law school in 2012
and i thought i wanted to just go like
big law commercial litigation
be in a courtroom and after about a year
um
at a law firm i was like this is just
not for me i
i really decided that i wanted to be
either in-house or
just working in a in a specific field
that i was really passionate about so
i am i started doing in-house counsel
work for traditional finance companies
and then i was recruited by silvergate
bank in
2014 because they wanted to help bank
the crypto space
at that time you know even the large
reputable exchanges couldn't get a bank
account because
there was this impression that you know
there was more money laundering going on
used for criminal activity all these
sort of like narratives
and um so i joined silvergate and i i
had known about bitcoin
and um my boyfriend at the time and i
had started buying a little but it was
still
just i was getting my head wrapped
around it and then when i joined
silvergate it was like um
my job was reviewing every major
exchange in every major crypto company
to see if they
had a you know a compliance program
a information security program
cyber security all the things that would
be needed to make a company safe
and bankable and so by the time i left
silvergate after like two and a half
years i had reviewed
um in like 200 300 crypto companies and
i had this like amazing
bird's eye view of the industry and like
where everyone sat the results of
certain exchanges
regulatory exams just like the whole
world of what was going on at that time
um and then i moved up to san francisco
and
and started to focus more on in-house
counsel for specific companies so i was
at bitfire
which is uh the largest bitcoin exchange
in japan
and at the time they wanted to expand
into the u.s so i helped them get the
new york bit license and all the
you know requirements to expand here
into the united states which is no small
task and then most recently was at
coinbase's regulatory council so
um it's been a really exciting journey
and like
with every year i spend in the industry
i fall more in love with it and just
like the people in it and what we're all
doing
and um you know even as nerdy as it
sounds like
the legal implications and what we what
we're having to deal with so
it's really exciting yeah i can imagine
because
like i was saying there's just so much
going on and we just don't know what we
can and can't do
and whether it be major institutions
getting in whether it be you know taxes
whether it be which countries are doing
what there's just so much going on
and i think people like yourself are
just so important just to be like wait
hold up
like we need some information as to what
what is happening
so so did you did you know anything then
about crypto before you
delved into it did you sort of just
learn on the job well what's funny is
like so before
silvergate i was at a traditional
currency exchange company
so um in i was in san diego that's where
i went to law school and in san diego
there are small
exchange centers along the mexico border
where workers
either on the mexico side or the united
states side need to like be
exchanging their pesos for dollars
they're you know depositing their
um paychecks that sort of thing that
also has money laundering concerns it
can have money transmitter licensing
implications so that's part of the
reason silvergate
recruited me is they were saying well
you know what you're doing
at this traditional wholesale currency
exchange company
is actually very much in line with
crypto i mean crypto's
sexier it has more like tech behind it
it's more revolutionary but
when you get down to the basics like
people can use it for money laundering
so you need to have an anti-money
laundering program uh
it can be considered money transmission
so you need licenses in every state
and so there's actually like a lot um
there was a lot of similarities where
there was definitely learning on the job
i mean it's when i started looking at
um when i started learning about chain
analysis and elliptic
uh and when i was at silvergate bitcoin
was the only
coin that existed like there was like
that was
in the early days where the what is the
security and what is not
didn't exist but um but yeah so there
was a lot of learning on the job but
you know the silvergate bank team is
still around that bank is thriving with
their crypto practice and so
there was a really great team to learn
with you know and like
uh expand our knowledge on the space
so outside of the as i said outside of
crypto what else did you do in your
spare time
other than stay locked home because
you're covered um yeah outside of crypto
what else do what else are you up to
yeah hobbies seem funny now um well so
even before covet but now i've
definitely been focusing more on cooking
i used
when i was in law school and waiting for
my law bar results i
started like a very amateur cooking blog
um but you know what would you cook
i mean i love pastas i um i don't do
like baking i just do like the savory
um i've been i've been playing around
more with the grill lately and marinades
and that sort of thing
so just just anything i really like um
you know i go through a lot of cooking
books and cooking magazines and just
sort of like
use recipes and tweak tweak them a
little
um but also like i mean in southern
california right now the beach i mean i
love just going to the beach walking
around with my dog
yeah it is it is a 74 where i am right
now
and um and i'm originally from dallas so
all my friends last week
were dealing with the like you know yeah
power outages
um snow and i feel
very fortunate like for the weather
we're experiencing here
and so yeah just hiking um but kovitz
changed things i mean before
covid i loved um like yoga
classes you know going dancing
like concerts sporting events i mean so
the world's just changed right now yeah
i'm with you
um but yeah it's a shame oh gosh me
and no one ever asks me what do i like
really
put me on the spot i like i like the sun
like i like i like outdoors i like
nature
i'm hoping i'm should be leaving the uk
permanently really soon so
i'm hoping just to get in the sun beach
i like dancing as well um i'm not
amazing at cooking which is annoying but
other than that
other than that you know cool well i
won't i won't put you on the spot and
ask where you're going but um i hope
it's somewhere
where somewhere fun i will you'll let me
know i'll announce it soon yeah i'll
announce it soon so
i promised everybody that we would talk
about heather because
tether's been crazy we've had this
tether filed that it's
you know not backed one-to-one with the
dollar that it's
um you know pumping up the price of
bitcoin
so obviously yesterday we heard the news
that tether and bitterness obviously
agreed to settle
um with the new york state attorney for
18.5
million dollars so can you take us
through
and understand what exactly is happening
here yeah i mean
it's hard because there is a lot of sort
of like
what what new york is saying versus what
bitfinex is saying and what
you know what what they're claiming so
the situation
with any sort of stable coin like this
and i'll use quote mark stable coin
is that the coin is pegged to something
it can be
it can be the dollar it can be a basket
of assets it can it can really be
anything but it needs to be pegged to
that to
um help ensure that there's less
volatility
um and and that there is consumer
protection
efforts involved and so you know i
definitely
do think that a lot of the news not even
just about tether but just in general is
fun
you know people like to have click bait
titles um make it seem like this whole
thing is this like scary
industry wild wild west i mean we've
been dealing with that for like 10 years
just
that general narrative um and it's
that's something i really try to avoid
writing for forbes like i would get paid
per click but i'd rather
the title be and the article really wait
you get paid per click
i didn't know that contributors do i
mean there's
there's certain like yeah certain i
think certain
news um news places do per click some
do um so at least for contributors
uh and that's i mean and not just forbes
like journalism in general
sometimes you are um incentivized to
make sure that it's something
that is going to cause you know stir or
get attention so
anyways my point is just that like i
think that there is fud
out there about this and about
everything but um
but i think the settlement shows you
know
they were the companies and the project
was very careful not to like admit
guilt really in that settlement but
it also shows um that they weren't
wanting to continue sort of fighting and
and proving it wrong i would say
um or they didn't want to continue using
their resources and
and money to keep fighting it um
so you know it's hard it's hard to say
really but
i do think that there seems to be
something
going on where it's not it's not a
hundred percent
true that it's pegged one for one to the
dollar
or wasn't at a certain point in time um
and i think
it's sort of that that um dishonesty
that
is is leading to new york pursuing this
so
aggressively because if you have
um consumers that are relying on things
that a project
is claiming um and then those things end
up not being true
you know consumer protection has always
been i think something that
people actually don't focus a ton on in
the industry they're they're
busy with the sec and uh fenson and ofac
but
you know we don't we don't want a bunch
of consumers being hurt by
misinformation so um
but it's interesting and you know i
don't i don't personally have a lot of
opinion on whether tether was
doing things to um manipulate or change
the price of bitcoin i i don't think
that that's
that's not what could like would concern
me about the situation
um but it didn't help the news didn't
help bitcoin's price yesterday
i would say yeah absolutely it didn't um
but see where i get really stumbled
across um these when it comes to these
things is the fact that they had to
settle for 18.5
million despite the fact that they still
denied any wrongdoing
so i'm just so uncomfortable with that
because i do understand the point in
settling i get it
like you said you know here just take
the money and we'll call it a day
i get that but if there was no
wrongdoing surely you can tell me if i'm
wrong anyone in the comments can tell me
if i'm wrong but if there was no wrong
doing 18.5 million no
it's not it's not it's not like a couple
thousand and i know it's obviously not
that much for them but
it's a it's a hefty it's a hefty amount
for not doing anything wrong
yeah i mean i i think i think you're
getting at the the
argument though that probably that that
that amount of money isn't that much in
compared to what
what they've been able to you know yeah
make um so it's it's more based probably
on percentage but um
but i would agree i mean i don't i think
that you know companies get put in this
hard
position where they need to choose if
they're going to continue fighting
and like you said pain and spending the
time and money
to try to prove their innocence or if
they're just gonna say you know what
let's just call it a day
um and and i think likely that's part of
what's happened here
um but there's also a situation you
could argue where if if all the facts
were really in your favor you would keep
going
you know you would you would continue to
fight fight the good fight so it's hard
to say yeah
and i don't know if anyone in the
comments does have does have an opinion
about that but
in general i would just say that the the
amounts that were seen
in these settlements and even like um
enforcement
enforcement actions like they do seem
very high i mean there was
um an article i read a few weeks or
months ago
where bitgo settled with ofac for
um i think it was nine thousand dollars
of transactions that
that went to prohibited jurisdictions
so it's not like they went to someone on
the ofac
sdn terrorist list they went to
jurisdictions that
that of themselves are considered on the
blocked list
and so for nine thousand dollars of
transactions
they settled for almost a hundred
thousand dollars you know and so
you start to like i feel the same way
sometimes where i'm looking at it and
i'm thinking like
you know it's just it's getting it
getting it out of the way
and um but sometimes it does seem a
little like unbalanced
do you have an opinion on it so do you
think that there was any wrongdoing on
teddy's
part or are you not allowed to sort of
give me um
i i don't think they're completely
innocent i think there must
be i you know i don't look regulators
um some regulators may have a problem
with this space but regulators don't
just like
go after a company for no reason and so
for new york to be kind of um
pretty transparent and saying there was
um misrepresentation about the backing
i think that i think it's fair to say
that that's partially true
i don't know how true and i don't know
the the gravity
of it um but that's that's what i'll say
i wanna so i think that leads me on to
the next thing that i wanna talk about
because
the um ripple um i think it's called sec
versus
howie i think that's the name of the
official um court case so that obviously
happened there was there was an
amendment that happened this week so i
wanted to get
your opinion on it um and i kind of want
to go through it chronologically
so i'm thinking i want to first
understand and i know i've been through
this but i still think there's
um some confusion around i do want to
understand what
a security is why they're being accused
of being a security
um the amendment and and then and then
we'll go on so let's let's do this
chronologically because i think it's
quite a hefty
subject so go for it yeah so
um yeah so sort of the background is
that
there was the case the sec versus howie
um it was from 1946 and
um you know i don't want to like sort of
repeat what everyone knows but for
anyone who doesn't it was actually about
an orange grove
and what the case was trying to litigate
and determine is
when is something an investment contract
when is someone um
relying on efforts by someone in hopes
of um making money it's just kind of as
simple as that
so you know that was 1946
the securities act is from 1933
so we're dealing with like case law and
um and regulation very old
and so now you fast forward to present
day
and um and there's been a lot of
confusion around this
because um ver pretty early on the sec
sort of said how the howie test that
comes from that court case
is the same test that you need to apply
to kryptos so that's sort of the basic
um i don't do we can talk about like
what those four
like there's four pro yeah yeah go for
it essentially i think i think the
confusion is
like because ether was kind of ruled out
as not being a security
so why is that different to xrp
yeah that's that's a fair question so so
um at the very basic the howie test
determines if something is an investment
contract
and so there's four prongs um
it's if there was a common enterprise
an investment of money in that common
enterprise
with the expectation of profits derived
from the efforts
of others and i do so for those four
um to be an investment contract you have
to
meet all four and that might seem
difficult but actually i would argue
that
a lot of the projects in the space meet
those four
and i'd argue the same that's how my
confusion comes in
yeah and it's not a very popular opinion
and i actually have a lot of potential
clients that come
to me and say you know we want to do
this this is what we want to do and they
lay out
the things they're wanting to do with
their project and their token and i say
what you just described as an investment
contract like
so we can either figure out ways to
get rid of one of those prongs um
and you know not to get around the law
but like to to frame your project in a
different way
or let's go talk to the sec
let me just ask you this then so with
that in mind then if you sort of feel
like you know
this is a common denominator within the
space
do you feel that the sec are going after
ripple xrp specifically because they
believe that they've done something
wrong
or do you think this is a general sort
of attack on the space
because i guess you know they were doing
things in some ways they were looking to
re you know replace the banks
in terms of those international payments
so
so i don't i don't interpret it as like
an attack on
the industry or like trying to promote
the bank
um i mean there's definitely there are
definitely regulators
in the us and there's definitely reasons
why some people
want banks to succeed and crypto to fail
like that's i agree with that but when
it comes to ripple like
the first thing i'll say is i don't
think ripple's the only project that's
going to see this issue
like behind the scenes i think um
it takes the sec a while to sort of
accumulate
all the evidence and things they want to
include
in a um in a case against a company so i
don't think ripple is the last
of its kind i think we're going to see
it more
and i and i don't love that i you know i
really wish that we could
as an industry like have the clarity
we've all been asking for
rather than these lawsuits or
enforcement actions so
so that's sort of one thing i don't
think that this is the last we'll see of
of this and so i don't think it's
specific to ripple but
um part of what i think the issue with
ripple is
is that they you know there are a lot of
uh exhibits within the allegations
that ripple uh really sort of marketed
xrp and promoted it and even promised
profits so if you go and like look back
at the four prongs
uh an investment of money people did
that
in a common enterprise ripple is that
um with the expectation of profits
so that's one prong where you know it's
maybe up for debate if people thought no
this is actually like a new payment rail
that we want to support not this is a
coin i want to buy for it to go up
that's one thing you can debate and then
derive solely from the efforts of others
i think people make the argument that
ripple feels
fairly centralized so i think that
plus the statements that they've uh you
know included
in the lawsuit about um
sort of promising the future uh
and promising profits or promising
success of the
coin and increase value
i think that that is a hard um those are
those are pretty easy facts for the sec
to point to
and so you know it's unfortunate like i
am i mean people i think some people who
follow me on twitter would think that
i'm like
anti-xrp or anti-ripple i'm not
like i i've never invested in it or
purchased
that wouldn't answer yet if you haven't
if you haven't invested then you must be
asking
so you know and i don't even i don't
even hope that this turns into some
horrible thing for ripple or xrp you
know i really
don't i i have no ulterior motives like
against the project
but i do think that for now like
you know um crypto mom has like
suggested for with the sec that we have
this like she's proposed a three-year
safe harbor that would allow a comp a
project like
ripple and xrp to reach that level of
decentralization
um where it could arguably not be a
security after those three years and
within those three years
the project would have to disclose a lot
of things but for the time being
the sec hasn't you know pushed that
forward hasn't agreed to that and so we
are where we are
and it's um and does it stifle
innovation and projects yes 100
um but it's still the framework we have
to work in
i mean that's the kind of narrative that
we saw with ethereum i mean that's why a
lot of people that's why i compared it
to because it's kind of the what i keep
hearing people often like you know
that's what people did with the theorem
at first and now it's decentralized and
so on but
there was one of them there was an
amendment this week which changed it so
can you explain what this amendment was
um i believe it's quite
a good thing essentially for yeah
so i wasn't following it as closely this
week as i normally would but they did um
there was an amendment where
the sec has amended some of its claims
and
i believe removed the um
manipu market manipulation claim yeah
that isn't um that isn't saying that the
sec
like the sec is still moving forward
with its claims that it was an
unregistered security offering
um but i think that that is a positive
if you're
you know following um because it shows
it shows that some of the claims that
the sec initially
included um are being dropped
but um you know i i i think it'll be
interesting because
we're not getting sort of any there's
there's a chance that the sec made that
amendment
to help promote a settlement but uh
okay but what i think more so is
probably that they
dropped that you know that they made the
amendment but that this may actually go
all the way to
to trial and um you know i think that'll
be really interesting and
again i don't i don't have any like
specific hopes on the outcome of that
but i do
if it goes all the way to um
you know litigation and it doesn't
settle well we might
start to get some clarity or we it may
just be
yeah it hit these four prongs and we're
gonna all be like
back back to where we started but
the most interesting part of all of this
for me is kind of just like trying to
understand where this is gonna look in
the future so
do you think if you know there's clarity
is given and we understand whether it is
or isn't a security
but number one by the time that happens
would something would would another
project have come along and
you know done what xrp was going to do
and you know replace swift and so on
or do you think actually now that it has
that clarity even if it is let's say
two three years down the line it can
actually go on to do what it's supposed
to do and all those bag holders are
gonna be real happy
yeah i don't it's hard to tell i mean i
guess my hope
really would be this safe harbor thing
would move forward
i'm a big fan of it i wrote an article
in forbes about it
and you know there's been a change
within the sec gary ginsler is now there
um from the statements i've heard from
him though
i actually think that he i don't think
he's skeptical
or dislikes the space but i do think
that he
has been pretty clear that he he thinks
xrp
you know ripple is a security and that
um
you know that even other projects i've
seen statements by him about
facebook's libra project and things like
that so
you know it's hard it's really hard to
tell it's hard it's hard to see in the
future
i you know there's a statute of
limitations within
within some of these claims i think
don't quote me but
i think it's around five years for some
of these securities
uh claims and so um so we'll we'll start
to see i mean
i think i think we'll start to see in
the next
i don't know i would say the next few
months there may be some more activity
coming out of the sec and
i don't know that because of any clients
i have or anything like that but just
from conversations i'm having in the
industry um
maybe the next maybe the next year will
give us some some guidance on where this
is all heading
you mentioned um facebook's libra i just
wondered if you had any thoughts
on that um like your opinion on it
yeah it's just not taken off i don't
know yeah i think well i think they
really kind of so for one i'm not a huge
fan of facebook i
think i mean to me it's like if we could
figure out a way to decentralize
facebook and people could be
compensated for their own information
rather than giving it to mark zuckerberg
and
making him money off advertising that
would be
ideal but um but that aside like
i think what happened with that project
is they launched
and they didn't really think about how
u.s regulators would
react so so with libra different than
like
usdc or tether libra was trying to say
okay we're going to make a stable coin
but it's going to be backed by a basket
of assets it's going to be
it's going to have the euro the end like
all these different
um and we as a association are going to
determine
um what percentage of each and the us
government was like
you don't get to choose monetary policy
like that right like you don't you don't
get to
make other countries currencies
more or less important than the us
dollar
in this like basket of assets so i think
it would have had a much
different i think it would have taken
off if it had
launched just pegged to the u.s dollar
i'm guessing they didn't because they
were hoping it would be more of a global
currency i guess but i think that's what
like
made all those letters come out and
hearings and everything
yeah so i don't really know i mean they
they've reached they've changed their
name to dm
now um you know so maybe they're looking
to sort of like re-remarket themselves
um you know i i've i was on a panel
yesterday with their general counsel
dms and he he's great i mean i was on a
panel with him and brian brooks from the
occ
um and and you can j he's really
passionate about
the the idea of a stable coin and a
digitized dollar so
you know i'm not like i i'm not against
the project at all but i do think
they're they're going to need to pivot a
little
yeah 100 they've already i mean facebook
number one has just terrible
um connotations to it at this point i
think i think even mark zuckerberg as an
individual people just don't like
anymore
um libra to me i just remember when the
whole thing started back in was it 2018
it just never got any good reputation
any good kind of
um marketing or publicity i think i
remember the backers
pulled out as well at one point um
yeah there was like 20 people in the
association i mean including
uh zappo coinbase i mean there were some
exchange companies
uh or crypto companies in there and then
um
yeah when all the you know letters from
congress and things started coming out i
mean paypal dropped like there was just
like this avalanche i
i believe none of the cryptocurrency
companies pulled out
um so i believe that they're still
members of the association
um and so you know i think that that
shows that there is some support
or at least that they that these
companies are seeing the potential of it
but it hasn't like it hasn't met that
potential yeah
yeah i mean if facebook cryptocurrency
digital asset is inevitable
like amazon are talking about one it's
so inevitable
um but there's been some stuff going on
in the u.s so i want to get your
thoughts because i'm british
and i've no idea what's happening so
just break it down for me so
so so we were kind of talking earlier
and i was sort of really
interested in regulation um because it's
a conversation we're always having in
terms of whether it will stifle
innovation in this space
um i've been seeing what's been going on
in nigeria and how their central banks
have basically stopped um
basically stopped um financial um
regulated financial institutions from
trading cryptocurrency so that's been
damaging there but
obviously i want to kind of get the u.s
perspective and whether you number one
imagine anything happening quite like
that and
number two i know that um is it janet
yellen
i know there's been a lot of hostility
with her and ginzla so
who are these characters because i don't
actually know so take me through i guess
how the us landscape looks
yeah so so yeah i mean your first
question is
do i ever could i see a world in which
there's
some sort of that level of restriction
on cryptocurrency in the us
um i i don't i think that
what we'll continue seeing is certain
companies or certain projects
struggling with regulatory um
you know enforcement actions or
settlements
but i don't think that they'll ever be a
situation where um
you know financial institutions are told
they can't um
you know they can't be part of the space
in some way
and actually what we saw for the last
you know six months or a year
was brian brooks who was formerly the
chief legal officer of coinbase i worked
closely with him
um and he joined the occ which is the
office of comptroller of currency
so the occ is within the treasury
department of the federal government
and they one of the things they do is
handle
you know bank banking regulation and
licensing
and so obviously brian is a huge fan of
cryptocurrency he came from coinbase
like there's no um
that's no secret and but he but he was
able to really go into the occ and have
conversations about like
this is where this things are heading
this is what it means to be a bank
and nothing about that
doesn't include the right to touch
cryptocurrency in some way
um so going back to like my silvergate
bank days there were these companies
that
couldn't get a bank account and they're
still there's people are still
struggling with that right
but like for one if if something is not
illegal
like so marijuana for example in the u.s
is illegal on the federal level
it still is i don't think it should be
but it is and so that means
a bank is going to have a really hard
time explaining why
to their federal regulator or their
regulator in general why they're
providing a bank account to a marijuana
company
on the other crypto's not illegal on any
level
uh you need to be you know you need to
be registered as a
broker if you're going to list a
security you need to have an anti-money
laundering program
there's a lot of rules around it but
it's not illegal at all
so so even back to the silvergate bank
days or today it's like why
is it hard for a crypto company or a
person
buying crypto to have or maintain a bank
account
that just seems crazy and so and it's
always seemed crazy to me it's part of
what i
really loved about silvergate um but so
brian you know put out a lot of these
letters and guidance over the last six
months that said
um hey banks you you can and you should
provide bank accounts to crypto
companies national banks like the big
name banks
you shouldn't be de-risking and not
banking these companies then you know a
few weeks or a month later he said
hey banks you can and should be if you
want and
in your business model be custody and
crypto assets
like it's no different than the fact
that you've always
offered safety security deposit boxes
at your bank like just it's
the technology's different but it's not
it's not um
changing or expanding on what a bank can
do
it's just keeping up with the time so
anyways brian
and the occ made all these great um
i would say like advances for the space
and we see anchorage and some
custom some companies actually going for
um special purpose trust charters or
full national bank charters now with the
occ and that's something that
never would have happened a year ago um
but then yeah we have this transition of
power the biden administration's coming
in
uh and i you know janet yellen is
interesting because
she so she's taken over for the treasury
um i i wrote a pretty like strongly
worded forbes article about some of her
initial statements
because she kind of came out you know
while she was being nominated and
and introduced and said yeah and i just
promoted these
things that like are just so i mean so
ten years ago i
just say like i mean so she she had said
i forget the phrasing like that that
crypto is is
mainly used for illicit activity and i
just lost
that yeah like and i mean
my fourth article was professional i
didn't like actually lose my but i
was just like i was close because it was
just
like how are we still talking about this
and it's also just ignorant and just
like shows a lack of
research and and time i think that's
just intellectual laziness and i think
that's kind of shocking for
someone in her position personally i
think it's that and i think it's
saying what she thinks her peers will
relate to
yes um and that's frustrating too
because you know
i mean yeah i think i think it's kind of
based on her audience
and who she's trying to speak to and so
i mean
is it we're in an interesting position
like biden
has said that he you know when there
were the whole hacks on twitter
remember when like yeah people lost
control over twitter
biden was one of them and like the
hackers who took over the accounts on
twitter
were making it like a bitcoin like
fundraise or some you know and at that
time biden said that he didn't
he confirmed he doesn't own any bitcoin
but besides that he's never said
anything
else and trump actually is the one who
during his administration
tweeted all that negative stuff about
bitcoin
so you know we don't we don't have any
indication that like
the biden administration is going to be
harsher or worse for the industry in the
us
um but this some of the statements by
janet yellen like this week she said
that cryptocurrency is inefficient
yeah these little things that i don't
even know really
where they're like i don't know where
they're coming from or even what
what's like what the incentive is to say
that you know what i mean like she can
have that opinion that it's
but like i'm not sure where
what i think the incentive yeah i mean
the incentive just comes from
the the same way we see banks behave um
hostile towards cryptocurrencies i mean
in the uk
banks are absolutely a nightmare
sometimes when it comes to cryptos um
the fca
who's our financial contact authority um
they're
it's just not so straightforward and i
think it's because they
see it as a threat um to the natural
status quo the natural kind of
way and the system basically because i
think it is
you know decentralization essentially
means nobody has control nobody's in
there's not one central authority and
that's obviously gonna um
rub the establishment the wrong way and
i think that's kind of maybe
what it comes down to um yeah on my on
my panel yesterday
when we were talking about stable coins
um
the panel sort of was talking about it
as like a baby step
because before you can expect these
regulatory agencies like you're saying
to be comfortable with this like
with every with having absolutely no
control and no power and no
um sort of even like the volatility
aspect
um like to me stable coins are like the
baby step in between it's sort of like
you get the regulators comfortable with
stable coins they're not that volatile
they're tied to your dollar like you
know yeah and
then get they're starting to get
comfortable with like centralized
exchanges oh it's
you know coinbase it does the same kyc
as a bank does everything's okay
you can't just like look i've been in
the space a long time i'm like
very into this idea of like a
decentralized exchange where there's
really not
this need for like kyc and surveillance
but we're not
like in my mind we're not there yet but
no kyc can we get there from a
regulatory standpoint
that's a good one yeah yeah it is and
then that's why i'm kind of saying like
you know so the reason i think we maybe
can or we can at least get closer is
like
um i can sometimes compare this to the
like to the internet days and i've had
discussions with zuko the founder of
zcash about this like
when the internet first came about like
the internet providers and even just the
hosted websites really wanted
the websites to be encrypted um and the
the government here in the u.s at least
um
and this is sort of a rough analogy
because i'm no internet expert but
but the the like the government agencies
and and the government in the us
was sort of like you can't encrypt it
like we the law enforcement needs access
to it we need to
they wanted that control and then as um
other countries started like
hacking or stealing information or doing
these things all of a sudden the us
government was like oh that sort of like
um privacy element of it less control
and more encryption is actually a good
thing and now that's how the internet is
today so like
i don't i don't know if we could ever
get to a place where there's absolutely
zero kyc um but i do think that we're
still like having these baby steps
trying to get trying to like
get closer to this idea of like
like the libertarian ideals that started
this industry and saying
how do we find that happy medium because
like right now
right now i would argue that most of the
centralized exchanges are doing
more transaction monitoring and kyc
than banks you know they're they're
doing transaction monitoring on the fiat
side
knowing where the dollars are coming
from knowing where the
the cryptocurrency is coming from and
going to and you know it's just
it's crazy so um i hope i hope we can
get
continue to make progress educating i
mean education is a big part of this
like
um even my article about janet yellen's
um statements wasn't to like
um wasn't to like just like
try to to make everyone in the industry
feel better it's sort of like
if if people outside of the industry or
even janet yellen herself would
like read that or read chain analysis
like report that i referenced in my
article
that talks about like i have it i have a
little
it's like what did i say it was 2.1
of cryptocurrency transaction volume was
used for
illicit activity and money okay and
in 2020 that dropped to just point
34 of transaction volumes
so that literally means less than one
percent of cryptocurrency is used for
these reasons
and then janet yellen's over here saying
that that's what they're mainly used for
so it's just we have there's a thing
yeah there's a disconnect yeah i mean i
think more than a disconnect there's
like a lack of
research there um very insane um but
yeah it will be interesting to see how
it plays out i'll just say quickly
because i spoke to
um fluffy pony um about monero and he
put it really
really nicely for me he sort of said
that um because we're talking about kyc
and privacy obviously
and he sort of said look you know we
have cash right
once you have your cash nobody knows
whether you're paying your taxes
people don't know um how much you have
stacked under your bed people don't know
whether you're doing something illegal
with it you know buying drugs with it
nobody really knows
and he sort of said that's those same
aml procedures
will be put into place for things like
privacy coins cryptocurrencies and so on
um i think it's just a matter of moving
forward and innovating because
realistically like if i
you know i i receive payment in bitcoin
right so technically if i wanted
i could just not pay tax on that because
i just get this bitcoin and
there's no kyc and whatever but then i
can't do anything
because when i start you know buying a
house buying a car
thinking hang on leia you have not had
an income for you know
yeah so it's absolutely impossible
um yeah i think for some reason this new
technology just scares people
and and they make
people describe it and make it seem so
like it has so much more potential for
bad than dollars
and it doesn't like you said dollars
literally are pieces of paper and you
can go do whatever you want with them
so you know any any like
argument i or statements i hear about
bitcoin like that
like you can just change the word
bitcoin the dollars
and and that sentence is probably more
true
so um yeah i mean i i think that there's
a lot of value in financial privacy
i think that like you know the at least
in the u.s
like the events of september 11th and
now even covet in a way are being used
to justify
more control and more surveillance and
being already being argued like we're
protecting you you
you know we're protecting you but um
yeah i don't know as my favorite quote
goes when tyranny comes it will come
wrapped in the flag
that's my my favorite question that's
really good
yeah it's amazing um i'll just just off
the back of that actually
um i shouldn't get into this but i'll
just say it's the same thing in
the uk so we're not patriotic like you
are we we don't care about the flag here
actually if you
um if you wave a flag it's offensive um
even especially in england flag you
mustn't wave an england flag because
that means that you're
a nazi and um a skinhead and
so on that's basically what that means
um but the way that we show patriotism
is through our public services like
our national health service or nhs um so
that's our patriotism so this whole
covert thing for us is all about protect
the nhs save lives protect the nhs
you know so that's kind of the way so
that's our flag our nhs is our flag
so when tyranny comes it comes wrapped
in the nhs so it's the same thing
same thing but different yeah yeah
that's interesting i i love hearing just
like how the different
yeah how different places uh
view some of these topics because and
there there
are topics that i don't like i think
that a lot of people in the crypto
space um like maybe these topics
wouldn't be things that they think about
so
passionately if it weren't for
cryptocurrency you know what i mean like
i've always been passionate about this
idea of
of um like liberties and freedom and
not being surveilled um but if it
weren't for
cryptocurrency i'm not sure i'd be
questioning
the financial system to the level i am
so that it's
a pretty like powerful thing that we're
all involved in
that fascinates me um because so a lot
of people come
to crypto through crypto first but i
find crypto
through politics because i am a
libertarian and i do believe in freedom
um and so i come through the politics
angles so i'm so happy that i'm here
because i'm like people understand me
yeah people get me
these are your people for sure yeah
and it's neat that like i mean the the
libertarian
like aspect of this is obviously very
strong but
what's also neat is like you you meet
and interact with
so many like so many different types of
people that are coming to this space
and then all of a sudden there's this
like exchange of ideas where we can
start to like talk through this i mean
i i would say i'm libertarian too but
then i'm also coming from the legal
side and the compliance side where yeah
so i
you know but i can't ever you know my
stance isn't like
the government get like it can't be
right because part of this
is helping companies interact with these
agencies
to figure out a good compromise and so
it's yeah there's a lot of compromising
that has happened needs to happen
will continue to happen and we'll just
you know keep
keep having baby steps but um but no i
mean this
the the activity we're seeing with the
bitcoin price
the companies we're seeing getting in
and you know involved like tesla
things like it's yeah we're it's crazy
this is what i wanted to ask you i'm
just been sidetracked on some things but
i wanted to ask you actually about that
because microstrategy put another
1.02 billion in today um these people
are mental
and they're not mental they're they're
thought leaders and they're great
um but so they now own 95 so i think 95
of their balance sheet is now bitcoin
which is amazing but
we're hearing a lot about etfs we're
hearing about um
what michael saylor has done to actually
allow other companies to invest
through them um i don't know the tech
technical words for that honestly i
don't
i understand what's happened um but
my question is essentially why can't
companies directly just
buy bitcoin like tesla did like square
like microstrategy why is it so
difficult why did it why there's so many
hurdles i understand the price
manipulation obviously you don't want to
move the market too much but other than
that
from a regulatory standpoint yeah it's a
good question i mean
honestly i think part of what has made
it
made it so companies haven't done it
isn't as much the regulatory hurdles but
more like
getting getting the entire executive
board or board of directors on
on on board with exposing their balance
sheet
to this super volatile you know
investment uh in my mind like
the the you know elon musk like they are
these like thought leaders and i think
that it'll
it will pay off for them um and i i
but i but i think that that's part of it
i mean you know i keep kind of tying
things back to silvergate bank but like
when silvergate
when the ceo alan lane went to like the
board and said hey
you know i think this bitcoin thing is
going somewhere like i think we should
you know create a team of people that
does business development and legal and
regulatory reviews blah blah blah like
you know i i can't like speak to the
conversations but my impression was that
there was a little bit of hesitation and
it was sort of like this seems like a
gamble in a lot of ways like anything
involving cryptocurrency right now is
still a gamble and i don't mean like
gambling i mean it's a
um there's a bit of like um trust
in in in it that that the future will
you know that it'll that it's here to
stay and that it'll be around for a long
time and benefit the people entering
early
um so i think that that's part of it um
and so wait
just so i can understand better than are
you so going through an etf or like
going through
what michael saylor has essentially
created is more protection for the
company and therefore everybody
across the board is more likely to get
on board and be more comfortable with
this kind of investment
i'm not saying that as much and to be
very candid like i haven't worked with
clients that are
looking to do what what these companies
have done so i don't feel like i can
speak to it that much
in terms of like what what the process
has been for them but i
i guess i'm saying more that like the
companies that we
see who don't seem willing yet to to
make these big
efforts um to get into the crypto space
i think part of
the apprehension is you know well we we
even saw this week when
when bitcoin's price went down it hurt
tesla's stock
right yeah 20 percent petersham i love
that yeah all of a sudden you're like
tying in i mean bitcoins obviously not a
company but you're tying in
the reputational and success of a
certain
uh project or you know currency
um yeah your balance sheet so that's
that's more what i'm saying and
so but but i think that a company
that takes the time to to go through you
know have etfs and go through it
that way like yeah they've taken the
time internally also to
be having these discussions yeah i think
it goes back to what you're saying about
baby steps essentially
yeah yep yeah i mean
yeah i mean i i definitely
maybe not right now with the the price
doing what it's
i mean i don't really think the price
drop is that dramatic or that big
thing still like hovering around like
what is it today
what is it let's see right now it's a 49
49 oh yeah 49 05 9. so i mean it's
it's dropped quite quite a bit but it's
nothing i mean
i remember when i was at bitflyer
it was bitcoin was hovering around 10k
and the day we launched it is what is
the day it went up to 20k
as like brandon legal and
as in-house counsel and compliance i was
freaking out because i thought oh my god
i mean day one we have an influx of
potential customers because everyone's
like excited about this
10 to 20k um you know but
then then it was down to 3k i mean it
just so i don't think that
the price drop is that dramatic but i
also think that
other companies like you know companies
like apple or amazon come to mind like
some of these are also forward-thinking
companies and you know apple has apple
pay it seems like
they are going to want to to inch into
this
industry but they may be a lot of
companies may be sitting back and
watching
what happens with tesla and just how it
how it works if they actually start
uh accepting bitcoin payments for tesla
how the balance how it affects their
balance sheet and their stocks
yeah so people might just be like
sitting back and watch
learning so speaking of like speaking of
all this crazy price movement then
how's it been with like friends and
family is everybody just knocking on
your door like haley
get us into bitcoin yeah are they
already in
well so a lot i mean a lot of my family
and and friends i kind of like
nudged in or or sent a little bit of
bitcoin to them for their birthday or
something so i'm trying to like i mean
i'm excited about the space and i
uh like i i even some usually when my
kid
when my friend's children have birthdays
i'll give them like
twenty dollars of bitcoin and like give
the like i look too
like you're a present yeah i think so
well it's funny because i gave one of my
friends like three-year-old
a little bit of bitcoin like i mean i'm
talking like ten twenty dollars of
bitcoin
um but but then it then it like just
shot up and he was like i think it's
worth like two hundred dollars though
you know and like it's so so i you know
and i just think it's neat to like
i always tell people about like coinbase
urn or these ways to like get involved
or like
lolly that does the bitcoin um i don't
know there's a lot of ways
to that i suggest people like get in
without
feeling like they need to throw a bunch
of money into an exchange right away
because that can be kind of scary
um but yeah i mean i it was a funny
story just came to mind my grandmother
passed away this week and um as i was
sort of like saying
like talking to her what she was
unconscious you know like sort of in her
final days
i was like grandma like bitcoin's at 57
000. and my mom goes hayley don't don't
tell her that member she wanted you to
buy her
some bitcoin and it was just like it was
just a sweet moment you know like
yeah because she my grandma was always
really excited about the space and
actually like
i helped her give a presentation at her
old folks home about bitcoin and stuff
so yeah it was really she was really
interested in it but um
anyways yeah i think uh yeah but i've
but i've had people like old friends and
like people from my past
texting me oh i wish i had bought like
you told me to or
i did thank you so much or oh my god
what a crazy month for bitcoin you know
so there's definitely a lot of
like excitement and um my the number of
people impersonating me on twitter has
gone up so that's always
that's always a sign that the industry's
doing well but it's
like it's never ending and really
annoying so but yeah
i mean i think people are getting more
and more excited about it and i think
the tesla news
hit hard because people think of elon
musk as
as a visionary i mean he's like building
rockets to go into space
he his card designs are amazing i mean
he's a little i tweeted a while back
like he's kind of like the perfect
person to be part of the crypto space
because he's a little crazy
well unpredictable he's he challenges
the status quo
like those are all things that i think
of bitcoin and
itself and like a lot of the people in
the industry they're just a little
yeah they're challenging the status quo
and that's
i think that's important yeah i think we
were all really surprised that it took
him that long
but i heard maybe it was on clubhouse i
didn't i spent too much time there these
days but i
heard somebody say that elon musk was
playing poker with bitcoin
back back back way back when yes
like i'm talking years ago but i don't
know how if it's just a rumor or what
but
there's gonna be like bitcoin poker day
like we have bitcoin pizza day if people
if anyone can find out how much he
he lost that day that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah i'll be pretty insane well it
was kind of funny how he like
was i mean he he he promotes dogecoin
you know but like i'm like well add
that's your balance sheet then
see that see i wasn't gonna go into this
but like that's an issue
like that's that's an issue because you
and i
and the majority of people watching know
that that's a joke
but i'm not being funny i had so many
people intelligent smart people
approached me and asked me
if doge is a better investment than
bitcoin because also they feel like
their priced out of the market with
bitcoin they've
the ship has sailed um so i had a friend
who's like
leia jojo's really cheap elon musk is
promoting it it's already up shall i buy
it now
and i'm like girl calm yeah no yeah
well and what is i mean what is scary
and we
like interesting about is i forgot so
i think it was like a year or two ago i
started
opening accounts at every exchange just
because i kind of wanted to see all the
uis
you know like see whatever yeah like
what gemini looks like what
robin hood looks like what coinbase
looks like um
and so as a result like i would just
like buy you know
like 99 of my portfolio is bitcoin
but yeah with that one percent i was
buying like
you know ten dollars of this ten dollars
that i totally forgot i bought fifty
dollars of dogecoin
on robin hood like i don't know
two or three years ago and when i left
and i was just i was just going through
like the different accounts kind of
looking at the
at the random coins i had bought you
know i bought that
and a few others anyways but when i
looked at it it was like at an all-time
high and i
and i cashed it out for like 22 2200
for so 50 to 200 and i was just like
this is so crazy that like i mean
because it is a joke
and everyone kind of knows it's a joke
but like if it rallies like that and
people are making money like
is it a joke like i don't i mean it's
just really weird but i'm sure people
are losing money too
um i just got like lucky with the time
like i had totally forgotten about it
but elon musk was like tweeting about it
and i was logged in
and i was like does that say doge and
then i saw the increase and i was like
this is just
like i'm a secret genius yeah yes yes
that must be it
yeah i mean it is concerning because i
like people wish that they put their
life savings into bitcoin
so people are almost gonna do the same
thing with doge
especially on clubhouse it's really
interesting because there's a lot of new
people see the thing with twitter is
like is this echo chamber of people
already in a space
yeah we don't really have that kind of
ability necessarily to
branch outside of the spaces i think
it's a really tight echo chamber
but on clubhouse for some reason um
there's all these
new people that can and yeah it's really
interesting and then they ask
us about doge and we were just like whoa
like no
you know um not we're going on like
tangent after tangent but like
i know it's okay i got an invite you
know so i'm technically on
clubhouse but i've never actually been i
don't it's like is it that like is it
face to face talking or is it like
no uh do you know what i will i will get
it up on my phone um
give me a sec let's see so
yeah like it's important
it's just it's just voice so it's just
audio so
let me just jump into a room and
everything it just looks like that
basically
okay and and anyone can talk at any time
no so here you have the um speakers
the people with the blue are the mods
they're moderators i'm not blue sorry
green
can you see they've got green sets yeah
okay
and then it's actually really hilarious
this this thing
so you scroll down and you have um
these are the special people so
these people so these people are
followed by
the um by the speakers and then you have
the people who are in the dungeon down
here who are totally irrelevant
and these are the so-called peasants who
aren't followed by anyone and nobody
cares
i'm joking system on there i had no idea
that's so funny yeah there's a hierarchy
it's really really funny
i um uh stephen and preston who are the
other two law partners i work
a lot with at anderson kill like they're
both on it and i think speaking
and i jokingly told stephen yesterday
like
what what are you all doing on there
like do i need to get on there like
yeah you should i promise you you should
it's just like another thing to check
and do though you know it's like i know
and i've been to i've been like yeah
well okay i will
no i'm with you i'm with you i'm with
you it's annoying having to manage all
these different whether it's managed
work manage different social media apps
because
now work is social media um yeah so
i mean definitely i think um
i even have clients that i talk to on
like telegram
signal and so instead of like work
emails i'm getting like
work messages all the time from outside
clients not just like inside
slack so yeah it's just crazy yeah
it's mad um i i don't think i do email
anymore to be honest
it's all just it's all just telegram but
anyway we've been going for over an
hour so it's been such a cool chat haley
thank you so much
um it's been really good yeah it's just
been great i had so many questions i
wanted to ask you i'm always kind of
really interested in how what we're
doing will play out in in the wider
world
um and you know regulation matters in
that instance so
where can people find you show yourself
oh okay well yeah so my my handle is
haley london btc
i think i think it's showing under my
face right now
um but yeah i mainly i mainly am on on
twitter
um i i don't i try not to do too many
other things but i guess i'll be on
clubhouse now too
so so definitely follow and i'd love to
come back on your show like
later this year or next year when that
when we're when we have some updates on
some of these topics like the
um ripple xrp litigation and
and how the biden administration has
impacted us so
so yeah i really appreciate you reaching
out and having me on your show it was
fun
yeah it's been so amazing so haley thank
you so much again and guys thank you so
much for watching thanks for your
comments i've been reading them all
and they're all really great so i will
see you all next week on thursday bye
[Applause]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]